you can a computer have a sensation of
Happiness a and then B can it visualize
through a human experience or a sort of
perspective free fall in Einstein's case
well I think that it's important here as
in many cases to distinguish between
questions of principle and practice I'm
on bostrom's side in the sense that in
principle I don't think there's any
thought that human beings can think that
a machine couldn't think also but
there's a big gap between making that
statement and saying any day now we're
going to have uh theoretical physicists
replaced by artificial intelligence okay
because I don't think we're anywhere
close to that in the near term you know
human beings get hungry and we get tired
and we get cranky we need free energy as
physical systems to survive we're open
systems were dynamical to something
where maybe someday we'll have computers
who mimic that and then they'll become
very human-like in their thought process
I see no reason why not but again I
don't think we're anywhere close